okay so when we were talking about radar
we had a great reminder about how the
origins of that came right here at MIT
and in fact physically right here where
the Stata building is located well when
we're talking about instrument flying
there is a also a very strong connection
here to MIT so does anyone know the
story of Jimmy Doolittle and his first
blind flight yes do you want to share
yes you're right here's a lot of good
stories takeoff and landing just on
flight instruments yes good that's
exactly right and he also got his
doctorate here that's right you have a
good good understanding of him so so so
Jimmy Doolittle before he came to MIT
was flying in the military and he was
doing a lot of things he's known for
flying across the country in a very
short period of time and encountering a
lot of storms and weather and being one
of the first people to really rely on
the instruments inside your plane so all
your flight controls when you're not
able to look outside the airplane and
just as you said he studied here and got
his graduate degree here but even after
that he continued to study how a pilot
could fly when the visibility outside
the airplane was very difficult and
really pioneered the concept that in a
very foggy weather condition for example
you can still successfully fly an
airplane by relying on the flight
instruments and in particular one of the
most significant flight instruments is
what's called an artificial horizon so
Phillip already introduced that flight
instrument we'll talk about it and when
we've discussed that the sixpack where
you have these six circle flight
instruments it's the one in the middle
on the top and we'll look in that in
particular so that artificial horizon
with a little airplane on it it's
basically supposed to replace
getting outside your windshield and
seeing the real horizon and so it's a
good thing to rely on it's the most
important one of the most important
instruments when you're flying so so
basically instrument flying is how you
can rely on the technologies inside your
airplane to avoid hitting things and to
land without being able to see outside
your airplane and IFR stands for
instrument flight rules and so that
means that you have to follow a set of
rules when there are clouds outside now
because pilots really need to make sure
to practice and stay current we have a
situation where most of the time that
people are practising that instrument
flights might be a condition where
actually it is quite sunny and beautiful
outside but they're just practicing so
the way that we distinguish it is when
it's actually very foggy very cloudy you
can't see outside that is described by
IMC or instrument meteorological
conditions imc conditions so that's when
you actually have the condition where
you can't see outside the airplane and
then you follow your IFR your instrument
flight rules and to the goal of this
whole process is to be able to fly
safely even when you can't see out the
window so why why would you want to be
flying when you can't see outside the
window there are a lot of reasons for
that I've been spending a lot of time in
California and here's a familiar sight
in California if you see a you know a
lot of clouds a lot of fog fog is kind
of a daily occurrence depending on where
you are especially in the San Francisco
Bay Area and so a VFR pilot won't be
able to really fly in those conditions
at all
and then proceed to your destination and
desert our error is absolutely so filled
was just talking about like a condition
just shown in this picture here where it
might be the case that there's a thin
layer of clouds or fog at a low altitude
but if you were to go through that above
it it's really beautiful up above the
clouds and sometimes this is called VFR
on top so you have visual flight rules
up on top of the cloud so it's not that
you're flying in the clouds but you have
a cloud cover below you and so if you
have your instrument flight rating then
you can fly right through that thin
layer of clouds or fog and be flying in
a beautiful day above that I'd also like
to point out that instrument flying
makes you a better pilot so I know this
personally if you remember from
yesterday I talked about how after my
private basically the one of the first
things I did was start on my instrument
flight rating and you actually start
with just learning how to be a better
pilot you start sticking to your
altitude a little better you see when
you're a VFR pilot a lot of times when
we talked about the different airspace
there isn't a very strict restriction on
what altitude you need to be at you're
not really filing a flight plan you
could be changing your heading and
wandering over one way and wandering
over another way but when you start
training for your instrument you start
learning more precisely what it takes to
trim your aircraft's configuration
correctly how to stay you know at 3,000
feet you know one eight zero heading
whatever it is and actually maintain
that while you're doing a number of
other operations and your plane and and
not getting distracted in such a way
that causes you to change your heading
or your altitude so that just makes you
a better pilot altogether even in the in
visual flight conditions the reason of
course that you have to learn how to fly
more precisely is because when you are
in an actual IMC condition with clouds
and you can't see outside your airplane
you're relying on the air traffic
controllers to sequence the airplanes
and make sure they don't come near each
other and
the air traffic controller is going to
want to know that if they tell you to
stay on a particular vector so an
altitude heading you know and they want
to make sure you actually stay there
because if you start drifting off course
you could drift into the course of
another airplane that they have flying
in a different direction so you actually
are required to do some amount of
instrument training even for your
private pilot about three hours so that
means that you have to go flying and
rely purely on the instruments in order
to fly so it would be great if there is
a day that has you know fog without an
adverse weather situation so you could
actually fly in and true IMC conditions
where your instructor is really taking
control there but allowing you to
experience it but if that doesn't happen
you can use a view limiting device such
as foggle so those are basically glasses
you put on that kind of fog out where
you would see outside the window and
only are visible looking at your
controls or a hood that basically blocks
your view of everything except the
instruments so we've already talked
about radar and ATC and working with
those air traffic controllers so those
air traffic controllers are responsible
for the separation of the air planes and
they will assign specific altitudes
headings and different routes and
clearances nav aids is short for
navigational aids like radio and GPS and
then we've already discussed just now
about a transponder so that XPD are just
stands for transponder and that's we're
just basically saying that if the radar
itself is not able to provide the
accurate altitude of the plane you can
add on the transponder to help with the
radar return we've also discussed
briefly the ATSB and we will get into
when we talk about weather data how you
can build your own device to receive
that ADSP data so let's talk about the
different phases of an IFR flight so
there's a little bit more you need to do
in the pre-flight planning the flight
planning stage you also do need to file
a flight plan which we discussed isn't
required for your VFR flights and
some more things you need to do when
you're once you depart when you're on
route and then your approach to landing
so what Philip helped to help me pass
out or what's called approach plates so
you'll hear that so it's different
information that talks about when you're
landing they're different specific
procedures because again you can't see
outside the airplane so they will create
a path that you fly on that's
specifically designed to avoid terrain
and allow you to come in and land at the
airport safely so on the although I
passed out the physical piece of paper a
lot of people have physical pieces of
paper for those approach plates
I've also pulled up some an airport I
used Bedford my local airport and you
can go down and on for flight to
approach and see all the different
approach procedures so I'll pass this
around and basically you can click on
different approach procedures
let me also add that all these plates
are available free online if you go to
any source like skyvector aeronautical x
ER if you just want to have it in front
of you on your phone yeah absolutely so
you know pre-flight planning planning
it's just really important as much as we
just talked about meteorology and
different adverse weather conditions so
just because you have the ability to fly
in the clouds doesn't mean it's a good
idea if there is anything like
thunderstorms icing conditions something
that could impair your ability to fly
safely then it doesn't mean you should
go flying and it's really important to
kind of understand where all the adverse
conditions are and look at all that data
so when you're when you're doing your
pre-flight planning there's certain
information about you know when you need
to have an alternate so the time an hour
before an hour after your estimated time
of arrival your ceiling so what's a
ceiling again that's when you have a
cloud cover so either broken or overcast
clouds so they're saying if that ceiling
is less than 2,000 feet and then your
visibility so how far out you can see
three miles and one of the biggest rules
of thumb to keep in mind is that when
you're doing this that's planning you
don't want a situation where you take
off from an airport and you plan it such
that the weather is going to get so bad
that you can't return to that Airport so
a good good safe rule of thumb is make
sure that you can get back to the
airport you're taking off from in case
there's any issue with your airplane or
travel you want to be able to safely get
back from where you took off from and
even though with your VFR sorry with
your IFR rating you can fly through
clouds there are still specific
visibility requirements for every single
approach and Airport that you're coming
into it can't be a completely dense fog
all the way to the ground there is a
altitude where even the the big major
commercial jets have to be able to
identify certain runway indicators
before they're allowed to lay
if they're not able to they have to go
around or find an alternate airport and
all that specific information is on
those approach plates that we'll talk
about in a moment so you can actually
file a flight plan directly with with on
the computer or with an app such as for
flight this is what I was discussing a
moment ago this is your six-pack again
your flight controls and the one right
in the center at the top is that
artificial horizon and just as Jimmy
Doolittle did found that it's a very
important reference point that's really
what you want to spend most of your time
looking at when you're flying instrument
just like when you're flying VFR you
want to spend most of your time looking
out the window at the actual horizon and
what's out there you want to look at
this to make sure you haven't started
turning and not realized it so we're
gonna get into two human factors this
afternoon but just like we talked about
when we were discussing aerodynamics
your body can't really feel the
difference between gravity and
acceleration and so if you if you start
a turn but then you basically have even
even doubt and you're flying level you
might not notice your body will not
notice that you're tilted and so so
that's why it's really important to keep
an eye on this artificial horizon and
make sure you're in fact flying straight
and level when you think you are so
we're going to talk about a lot of
different safety considerations we
talked a lot about minimums with regard
to what are the FAA regulations or your
flight school might impose you know the
place you're renting your aircraft might
impose certain minimums you know that
they don't want you to take the plane
unless the ceiling is above 2,000 feet
for example but there's also this
concept of personal minimums and Phillip
and I will spend a chunk of time at the
end of the course talking about our
personal minimums and sharing them with
you that you might want to set your own
restrictions that you know hey if
certain things are occurring and you
don't feel comfortable you don't think
it's safe you set those restrictions to
yourself so that way on a particular day
that you're planning to fly you don't
get the get their itis where you just
really want
go and you decide you're gonna you're
gonna do whatever it takes you can refer
to your personal minimums and say hey I
have previously decided that this wasn't
a good idea so let's stick to my
judgment at that time and not fly we're
also going to discuss how you can even
though the FAA might require only a
single pilot in command you can actually
have a different person sitting next to
you whether they're a pilot whether
they're just a friend you can put that
person to work to help you out and
managing your cockpit and helping with
some of the navigation for example so
let's talk a little bit about the
approach plate so does everybody have an
approach plate either on their computer
or a physical piece of paper is anyone
missing one okay so there's a lot of
information on an approach plate and you
don't need to know any of this for your
private pilot but just so you get
oriented I'm just going to give you a
high level of what kind of information
is on this approach plate and what we're
talking about so again this is a
situation where it could be there could
be cloud cover or you're flying in fog
and so you can't see outside your
airplane or you can't see the airport
but you have to safely arrive at the
airport so the approach plate provides a
flight path for you to fly on to safely
enter the airport's vicinity enter the
final approach and then to a point where
you can visually identify certain runway
markings and land safely so the very top
of the approach plate tells you a lot of
information so the the top right corner
where it says our nav GPS that's
identifying the type of approach that it
is so usually it'll tell you whether
it's a precision approach or a
non-precision approach so there are
different types of instruments on your
plane so you'll see as that iPads being
passed around with the different ones
you can click on there are certain
instruments in your plane and at the
airport that will tell you how you can
land so an ILS for example an instrument
landing system if that is available it
can be a very precise way to land at an
airport whereas if you don't have
exactly those things available
you might use a GPS or a vor which are
different types of approaches you can
fly it also tell you the runway which is
very important runway one-six so that's
the runway you're trying to land that
and then just below it is the airport so
this one in particular is Portsmouth
which is an airport that's basically and
if you drive to the coast from here so
it's kind of at the border between Maine
and New Hampshire right along the
coastline and people refer to this
Airport as Pease you also see a lot of
very specific information a lot of
numbers and things there so we've
discussed a few times this ADIS the
concept of ADIS so you see that 8 it so
that's the frequency you can dial into
to get the weather information at that
Airport and you'll need to get the
latest weather information before you
enter and start doing the procedure you
also see the air traffic controller here
is Boston approach he'll you'll be
talking to you on one to five point zero
five you see the Pease tower or
Portsmouth Tower one twenty eight point
four and then after you land here's the
ground controller that you talk to do
you do we have to worry about those
other numbers like two six nine let's
make it simple and say no you don't have
to worry about this okay those are from
the military that's the UHF and you
won't have that in your rental Piper
another really important thing to pay
attention to is that the top right
corner is a missed approach so if you
were not able to complete the the
landing maybe you had to go around or
something didn't feel safe or you lost
communications when you're coming in and
you are not able to execute the landing
then you fly a missed approach so it
tells you what to do if you weren't able
to land so it says climb to 3,000 so
3,000 feet direct and it says this TT
ATT is the name of a particular location
so tat and then it says and on track one
six five degrees so that's the heading
to ID'd and hold so it basically says
that if you weren't able to land then
you're supposed to continue straight
climb to 3,000 feet to this tat location
and then on the track 165 degrees to
continue on to Aidid and hold so now the
middle of the approach plate really
tells you what to do there a couple
different points that are really
interesting
so IAF does anyone know what IAF stands
for initial approach fixed so these are
places where you can enter this pattern
so IAF you can you can enter here it I
taught there are a couple others here as
well so what it's saying is if you
entered here at I taught your flying at
3,000 feet on heading one one eight
degrees to this kind of holding pattern
right here then there's an in every time
it has these kind of weird letters is
representing another point and then you
continue straight into the towards the
airport to this other spot and then
here's the actual airport it says runway
one-six where you could land right here
and if you have a missed approach
remember it said to continue straight to
I to tat and then to continue on to
Aidid and you can do a hold over here so
aviators are not without a sense of
humor so let's just go through what that
would be what are the names of the
points along the way so it is you start
with I tawt I taw a puddy tat
I need so I'm getting a lot of chuckles
in case you missed that it's you know I
thought I saw a hoodie tat Aidid I did
see a putty tat
anyway good cartoon for you there so so
that shows you I have a little bit of a
humor in this particular approach plate
the bottom of the approach plate shows
that the same thing but kind of a
profile view so this shows that the
altitudes that you're going so you start
at 3,000 this is your heading you're
going along into I taw and then you go
down you're descending to puddi and then
all the way here where you land and if
you have to execute a missed approach
then it pictorially describes that
missed approach which is you continue
straight at 3,000 feet climb to 3,000 to
tat and then on heading 165 to Aidid and
then here on the left of course is a
picture of that runway and it tells you
you know what that runway looks like
kind of the taxiways around it the
length of the runway etc what are the
minimums how low can you go before
seeing the runway the minimums depend on
the type of aircrafts that you have so
that's I was skipping over it because
it's fairly complicated but this whole
this whole thing down here basically
indicates the minimums in terms of your
visibility as you're landing so where it
says category it's the different types
of categories of aircraft circling means
that if you were planning to land at one
runway but you circle to land at another
runway and then it has a lot of
specifics depending on the the actual
type of aircraft what about Anna Cirrus
a modern Cirrus you can go ahead
Phillips okay so that top one is lpv
that's essentially a precision approach
using the GPS so if you have a Waze GPS
which is the modern kind as of about ten
years ago you can go down to 300 feet so
if you don't see some indication of the
airport environment the runway leading
lights or something and you can't go
below 300 feet it's time to do a mist
and it also tells you you need 2,400
feet
visibility but in this case that 300
feet is regardless of the category
whether it's you know a B C D or E they
all show that same amount and when when
Philip is talking about depending on the
type so it's the whether you're reading
here the LP VL nav etc on the left
yeah like the L nav approach down there
towards the bottom that would be for an
older non waz GPS so there's obviously a
lot more information on this approach
plate but those are some of the key
highlights so you don't get afraid when
you see these any any questions before
we move past this topic yes somewhere
you can look up like why their name
oh yeah it's a good question so
basically if you missed if you missed
the joke the I tawt I taw a puttytat
joke is there a place you can look it up
I'm not sure but I know a couple of
people that write you know different
articles about aviation it'd be good
good exercise to see if we can google
and find a couple of those articles and
share where they figure out how they
name all these different points okay so
if you want to learn yes go ahead
the speeds yeah absolutely so what speed
you have to be as you're flying these
different approaches so yeah this is
talked about a fact if you're in a
really busy Airport they may tell you to
keep your speed up so that you know clog
off the works or the jet and also auto
pilots don't work that well if you're
going really slowly
so it's probably conventional and
something like a series to be going
around 120 knots before you get to the
final approach fix you're going to put
in one lots of flaps just before and
hundred twenty knots is a limitation
or series for flaps so you'll slow down
to maybe 105 as you're going down the
glide slope and then once you break out
of the clouds let's say it's 5 feet
above the runway although the minimum
there was 300 above sea level
which is 200 feet about the runway you
put in the full flaps and you know slow
down to your final approach speed if you
know 75 or 80 knots so those would be
the typical speeds on a precision
approach and if you're practicing your
new it's okay
okay to go a little slower they'll tell
you kind of if there are other people
behind you holds or a good time that you
know the whole point is to basically
take time and slow down they're trying
to get you to wait for some reason so
you might want to go 90 knots the reason
you don't want to go much below that is
you know of course you are doing so many
things in the airplane to get prepared
for the approach you don't want to you
don't want to get down into very slow
air speeds where you could stall as well
that could be a big issue so so now just
talking about how you go on to get your
instrument flight rating there's some
good resources here to point out and
just this talks a little bit about the
time that X C just stands for cross
country time then you actually need time
and actual IMC conditions or and
simulate it so that's where you're
wearing your goggles or your foggle your
hood and again you can actually do a
little bit of simulated flight training
as well so some places have a red bird
simulator other types of simulator we
can do some simulated flight time
sometimes that'll save you a little bit
of money because you don't have to spend
the engine hours to fly out to wherever
you're doing the approach and you can
just restart very quickly so there could
be some advantages of that and then
Phillip you have some advice here on how
you get your IFR reading yeah I think if
you're gonna do this you know once you
finish your private these higher
performance airplanes aren't great for
training the little fibers and Cessnas
are probably better just because they're
slower but as soon as you're going to
you know work on the instrument rating
and undo transportation you know and
then it's time to get into the serous or
get into the bananas
that you're intending to use for family
transportation time and type and
realistic going with an instructor on
the trips that you're actually going to
do is invaluable for safety I think one
good way to do it is do a big
cross-country trip with an instructor
just go to Florida go to California go
to Alaska and do an approach every hour
so then you go through a lot of weather
systems and you get very comfortable
with getting the weather information
filing the flight plans working with
controllers in different situations now
one other thing I would add it's kind of
a cool cool trick you might not have
heard of so whenever you're getting a
instruction you have to pay not only for
the aircraft rental but for the time of
your instructor well if you take a
instrument flight and you you know
practice an approach and then you just
want to practice it a couple times
yourself you can actually go up without
your instructor without any view
limiting devices of course where you can
fully look outside the airplane and you
can keep flying that same approach so
you can actually fly practice approaches
without actually being in an instrument
condition or with view limiting devices
to just practice the mechanics of the
whole thing you know how you deal with
airspeed who's gonna start talking to
you next what do you need to do next and
I find that to be very useful
you'll also find on that you heard from
Sebastian yesterday about the MIT flying
club so there's a there's an email list
flying - pilots at MIT that edu so once
you become a pilot it's great to be on
that list because instrument-rated
pilots have to keep practicing their
approaches and so they need somebody to
sit next to them to look out the
airplane for other aircraft while
they're wearing their view limiting
devices and that person is called a
safety pilot so as long as you have your
private pilot license even if you don't
have your instrument rating you can
serve as a safety pilot so it's a great
way and cheap way to get a lot of
practice in and see you know an
instrument pilot at work trying to do an
approach and you can sit there and
and you get to log that time as safety
pilot has if you had been flying so it's
a good way to build that flying
experience
there's a question for you guys so the
safety pilot you heard about the medical
certification let's say the person
practicing the approach has a first
class medical so they're very healthy
and the FAA thinks the pilot is unlikely
to have a heart attack and keel over
while under the hood does the safety
pilot need to have a current medical to
serve a safety pilot what do you guys
think it's kind of ridiculous that
person has a heart attack the regular
Piatt can just you know take off the
hood and fly so you the safety pilot
shouldn't need a medical right as long
as they their last words are you know
you have the controls but in fact the
safety pilot is a required crewmember
for that operation so the feds say that
he or she must have a current medical
and just that that joke that Phillip
said about you have the controls I'll
just take a moment to explain what he's
talking about when you hand over
controls you take the controls it's
important to have what's called a
positive exchange of controls so if I'm
if I'm flying the airplane and I'm
giving the controls to Phillip I'll say
you have controls I have the controls
you have controls so that reconfirming
make sure that you know who's flying the
airplane so that you don't result in a
situation where no one's flying yes when
you're handsome
I usually keep them on up until I really
know that he knows what he's doing so I
I actually keep it on a little bit
longer to make sure he knows and he
doesn't start you know turning in some
other directions yeah I think I'm that
third one you have the final important
in the helicopter and airplane the good
thing about airplanes is you can take
your hands off and the airplane just
keeps doing whatever it was doing but
the helicopter is unstable so yeah it's
important that the you know you don't
take your hands off until you hear that
third acknowledgment yes so the question
was how long does it take to fly from
here to California answer really depends
on which type of aircraft you're flying
so a little a little Cessna 172 would
take a long time because even it
basically is like twice as fast as a car
and it's kind of as a crow flies but if
you're flying a fancy Cirrus you could
get much faster where you get you get a
headwind
going west generally so it's probably
going to take about 15 hours to get to
California you know maybe a little over
20 in a Cessna or Piper and then they'll
get a little speed speed boost on the
way back so it's kind of like a lot of
people there are various companies that
offer you know ten-day instrument
ratings and they fly around a lot so a
couple weeks to get to California and
back is reasonably comfortable while
doing flight training along the way one
of the biggest things that'll slow you
down is not how fast your plane can fly
but also your own fatigue which we'll
talk about in human factors alright are
there any more questions on instrument
flight or instrument meteorological
conditions yes
so the question was what's our opinion
on steam gauge versus a glass cockpit I
think we know Philips opinion here I've
actually flown both I think that you
know with the g1000 or a glass cockpit
what's nice is you can load the approach
and it actually show you know the full
flight plan that you're supposed to fly
for a given approach and you can
actually have a whole flight plan where
you have multiple approaches one after
the other and it puts it up there and it
makes it makes it very easy but I will
say that to learn it I've actually done
instrument training on both the steam
gauge and the glass cockpit and I think
that steam gauge obviously keeps you on
your toes a lot more you really know
what's happening you're using your
you're heading bug to do a lot more
because you can't and enter some of
these things in advance and so I think I
think it's really helpful to learn how
to do that just like I think for example
your auto pilot is amazing you should
have an auto pilot if you're gonna fly
across the country but you shouldn't use
your auto pilot when you're doing flight
training because the first thing mark
Nathanson the FAA examiner will do will
be oh look your auto pilot died now you
have to learn how to fly without it so I
think for flight training I recommend
both the other the other reason I
continue to fly both steam gauge and
g1000 is that I fly with a lot of other
friends so we talked about the MIT
flying Club you fly with your peers
there's also a group of women pilots we
call ourselves a women pilots of New
England we basically bumped into each
other in the parking lots of airports
and and now get together we're actually
having a dinner tonight at 6:00 p.m. so
if any women pilots want to join please
do and and this different or pilots who
identify as women sure and and these
groups that you fly with on these fly
outs is often the case that you want to
you know have one have two pilots flying
in a given airplane and you one flies
there and ones P I see there and ones P
I see on the way back and so if you have
a lot of friends that fly the steam
gauges which are cheaper to rent you
want to make sure you're current in that
airplane if you want to fly with them
and if you fly a g1000 you want to make
sure your friends that you
would also fly g1000 so I fly both
because I have friends that fly both and
we want to make sure that we can fly
together on these fly outs yeah so
despite the fact that I usually fly
glass cockpit aircraft I do fly
instrument approaches in our 44
helicopter instrument trainers and them
and those are more challenging because
there's no there's no autopilot and the
machine is inherently much less stable
than the airplane
so that's steam gauges so I wouldn't say
there's a big difference you know really
the world of instrument flying if you
transfer your skills from the visual
flying world to the instrument world and
they do transfer very well you know when
you're flying visually you're spending
about 80 90 percent of your time looking
out the window at the natural horizon
when you transfer that to instrument
you're spending 80 or 90% of your time
looking at the artificial horizon or
attitude indicator and if you hold a
constant attitude the rest of the
instruments take care of themselves the
experience in some instructors will
often cover up all five of the other
instruments it's gets a little harder
with a glass cockpit you know a lot of
post-its and have the student the IFR
student try to hold the constant
attitude as best they can and then
remove the post-its after say 2 minutes
and you know you'll find that you've
only gained a couple hundred feet and
you've only lost maybe 10 degrees of
heading so really the game the FAA has
terrible advice about how to be an
instrument pilot they say you know scan
the six-pack so spend essentially 1/6
other time you used to spend 90% of your
time looking at the attitude indicator
now it's been one sixth of your time or
spend half of your time look at the
attitude indicator look at these other
things but if you actually study you
know high time instrument pilots or jet
pilots you'll find that they're really
focusing on the attitude indicator 80 90
percent of the time like I said and if
they don't do that actually once flew
with a guy he was an MIT grad an MIT PhD
and he just you know the FAA told him to
scan like this so he does and that
airplane was all over the sky but he was
constantly redirecting it you know he
was right within the
ACS standards of about plus or minus 100
feet and I don't know maybe it's ten
degrees of heading but we were in actual
conditions in a Piper arrow with pretty
limited backup facilities so that was
truly terrifying to see somebody
actually doing what the FAA says to do
the other thing about glass cockpits
that I do like is the the it's great for
night flying because the illumination is
very uniform so one thing one problem
with steam gauges is that at night some
of the instruments can be dimmer or
brighter than the others I actually had
a diamond star da40 and the attitude
indicator was the dim which is the thing
that you want to be using was the
dimmest instrument in the panel and that
was very annoying you know they were
backlit the instruments themselves had
the lights in there so they were showing
no no way to adjust it I think you're
gonna find the glass panel is what's in
almost every aircraft you know within
five or ten years because it's just
getting too expensive to maintain these
mechanical gyros if you send out a
mechanical attitude indicator to be
overhauled that's two thousand dollars
and you know the glass cockpit
replacement it might only be three or
four thousand dollars and don't ever
have to touch it again for the when we
we pulled earlier in terms of people
who've gone flying before did you
so I mean ask three things so was it did
you fly in a steam gauge airplane did
you find a g1000 or a glass cockpit or
did you have you flown in both so steam
gauge about half of you and then g1000
or glass cockpit only like two or three
okay and then if you've done both
only only a handful so actually it looks
like the well and of course they're a
bunch of you that haven't flown at all
but the ones that have it looks like
primarily in the steam gauges so that's
good to know
thirty years ago they hadn't been
invented all right that's true
well this was great and Philip talked a
little bit about night flying we're
going to have a whole section on night
flying tomorrow but now we're going to
do a break for lunch we'll give you
about 45 minutes to get get food please
come back a little bit before the hour
and we'll start we'll get started right
at one o'clock
thanks